son medidas fronterizas para evitar esas
nuevas variantes para restringir los
viajes internacionales a lo esencial es
habrá además muchos más controles
policiales y multas los ciudanos
británicos y residentes que vengan de un
país una lista de países en lista roja
entre ellos suramérica portugal y
sudáfrica tendrán que estar en un
aislamiento por diez días en hoteles
suministrados por el gobierno no hay
claridad en los logística sobre quién
pagará estos costos
además quienes salgan del país del reino
unido tendrán que presentar una
declaración de por qué viajan las
vacaciones ha dicho la ministra del
interior no son una razón válida ni
soberana en este momento las aerolíneas
deberán controlar que sea cierto lo que
estas personas dicen la policía
aumentará su presencia en puertos y
aeropuertos para preguntarles a los
viajeros por qué quieren viajar si la
razón no es suficientemente convincente
o esencial entonces tendrá que volver a
sus casas o serán multa
los viajeros de otros países no
prohibidos que no están en esta lista
roja que les mencionaba tendrán que
presentar una prueba negativa del coi
hechas 72 horas antes del viaje bien
importante también el primer ministro ha
dicho en el parlamento que sólo si las
medidas de seguridad así lo permiten las
escuelas podrían ser reabiertas el 8 de
marzo hay una polémica en el país porque
los niños dicen los padres deben volver
a las clases de una manera segura y
también es bien importante que el
gobierno ha dicho el primer ministro que
se publicara la estrategia de cómo salir
de este tercer confinamiento en que está
inglaterra la semana del 22 de febrero
entonces habrá 5 semanas por lo menos
más de estricto confinamiento